y
la bofetada se escuchó en todo el mundo
después de que una broma saliera mal en
los oscar
los comentarios de crisis rocks sobre el
peinado de lleida pinkett smith no
sentaron bien a su marido will smith
tras la bofetada en el escenario smith
gritó improperios al cómico
mantén el nombre de mi mujer fuera de tu
boca
poco después del incidente smith ganó el
oscar al mejor actor por quin richard
película en la que interpretó al padre
de las leyendas del tenis venus y serena
williams
el momento viral de smith eclipsó el
resto de la noche incluso cuando en la
categoría de mejor película se hizo
historia la película kodak de apple tv
ganó el codiciado premio es la primera
vez que un servicio de streaming se
lleva el galardón
el actor troy corser que interpreta al
padre sordo de una niña que puede oír y
quiere seguir una carrera musical ganó
el premio al mejor actor de reparto
otra novedad
es increíble estar aquí en este viaje no
puedo creer que esté aquí muchas gracias
a todos los miembros de la academia por
reconocer mi trabajo mi furia kick
nights in my work también tuvo su
momento de américa latina' la película
de disney encanto inspirada en la
familia madrigal colombiana se llevó el
premio a mejor película de animación
tengo que agradecer a todo el país de
colombia y a nuestro increíble casting
jane campion se llevó a casa el oscar la
mejor directora por el poder del perro'
mientras que jessica chastain con su
papel de tamiflu y bikers se llevó el
premio 'mejor actriz'
[Aplausos]
y para cualquiera que se sienta
desesperado o solo quiero que sepa que
es amado incondicionalmente en su propia
singularidad
nestares you la puertorriqueña harían de
bous siguiendo los pasos de rita moreno
ganó el oscar a la mejor actriz de
reparto por su interpretación de anita
en website historia
[Música]